4 par 4 à pain
que votre gaieté me réchauffe le coeur
il faut dire que je suis
particulièrement de bonne humeur depuis
que j'y retrouvais lille et les enfants
vous avez raison mais on a beau faire
venir une voyage l'amou-daria compagne
et la mère toujours avec un très grand
plaisir que l'on retrouve son chez soi
et ses camarades enfin
presque tous est à marare d'un et qui
vivez vous parle oui et bien un voilage
ne seront pas lourd de casimir
est quasi non non je ne suis pas content
de retrouver quasi nulles et pourtant
croyez moi j'étais prêt à faire de gros
efforts qu'est ce qui pousse un café les
voilà soucieux de vouloir établir entre
nous de très bons rapports dès le début
je l'invité hier soir chez moi afin de
lui faire admirer mes dernières oeuvres
d'art
miss culture qui me perturbe
il n'oublie gaza oui fabriqué avec des
matériaux que jamais aucun autre artiste
avait fait avant moi splendide mais
alors il vaut un haka son
casser une cheminée pire que cela il a
profité que j'avais le dos tourné
pour manger 3
et la huent même l'audace d'ajouter
après et ils sont succulents vos petits
fours monsieur 10 à
12 ans excusez moi monsieur disque mais
quand elle me mettais un yo mystérieux
était qu'il fait c'est très simple et
effet de moutarde de confiture de
fraises de ceux-ci s'écrase jets de
bananes
bonjour joly alors monsieur michel
bonjour colère
il est vraiment colère il va écoute
casimir c'est compréhensible il invite à
regarder ses oeuvres d'art et tu le
manges 3 enfin julie je ne pouvais pas
savoir que c'était décevant car j'ai cru
que c'était un plateau de petits
sourires qu'ils avaient préparées pour
me faire patienter tu sais il y avait
les éclairs a fourré à la moutarde avec
le sud un piment rouge enrobé dans du
miel et puis également où le joli petit
par l'état à la mayonnaise et aux
anchois avec de la confiture de ça
suffit qu'à finir cela dit on ne peut
pas lui en vouloir vraiment monsieur du
snop parce que vous avez d'art
ressemblait tellement à des petits fours
kazimiyah il est justement chami on
l'exposition devait s'appeler petit pour
casimir rien alors ne soyez plus fâché
parce que casimir involontairement vous
a trouvé que vous avoir été parfaitement
réussie
c'est vrai ça ramic les casiers
j'entends de plus du tout cher avoue
s'il pleut de tous âges chers amis
j'étais venu vous voir pour savoir si
vous voulez que je vous rapporte un
poisson pour le dîner oui vous allez à
la pêche non à la chasse l'acheteur
comment ils vont rapporter des poissons
de la chasse mais bien sûr les émirs je
vais la chasse sous-marine der garde
tout âge et j'ai mon masque là pour pour
regarder sous l'eau et puis j'ai logé le
tube qui sert à respirer par la bouche
du bois d'oingt est sous l'eau mois là
exactement puis je n'ai pas là pour
aller plus vite tu vois oui lâche pas
dessus et puis en plus je le fusil
d'accord plusieurs autres voilà qui
prend l'élastique inouïe tutti toutes
tes forces tu le mets au cran ici et a
plus qu'à appuyer sur la gâchette on
fait le marché pour voir à jamais de la
vie casée mais c'est trop dangereux on
prend beaucoup de précautions pour
utiliser ce fusil de chasse il faut
faire sous l'eau non est-ce que je peux
aller vous regardez duo déranger mobio
sûr que je vois tu empêché de prendre
une petite leçon aller allons-y allons-y
mon poisson
je voudrais hugo rade c'est là qu'elle
est nous voyons s'il vous plaît comme si
vous l'aviez se rallie à total
dit monsieur du sne me prends un beau
poisson je vais pouvoir inviter tous mes
amis à dîner tiens je vais appeler
léonard
n'est pas là c'est bizarre
il a dû aller retrouver touba et les
autres
ouais tu joues et
tu sais léonard si j'avais beaucoup
d'argent
j'achèterais un gros gâteau offert bat
pour le mot gtl pardi et après après
quoi avoir mangé après l'avoir mangé
j'achèterais un deuxième gros gâteau
c'est pourquoi fait pour manger tiens
pardi mais et après après de quoi et de
la fois le manger après l'avoir mangé
j'achèterais un troisième gros gâteau
coin tu aurais encore envie d'un gâteau
après en avoir mangé deux je crois que
oui culture ni sur comment veux tu que
j'en sois sûr
je crois qu oui
maintenant mais tous que tu es beaucoup
d'action oui oui
que tu achètes trois gros gâteau que tu
n'aimes ans qu'est-ce que tu ferais
frais
après oui
je me paierais un grand bol de chocolat
au lait pour faire passer mes trois gros
gâteau et un prêt
à presse
après ben je m'achèterai dé glace au
caramel à la vanille au chocolat à la
fraise à la pistache ça rafraîchit et
après après oui
après j'en sais rien moi j'en sais rien
du tout après
all à la paix au nar oui je suis malade
style le mal au coeur j'ai mal au ventre
fait mal à l'estomac
c'est à cause de toutes ces glaces de ce
chocolat et des gâteaux oh là là je vais
vite aller prendre un cachet pour
digérer tout ça moi en allant à manama
g ça y est il sage espace iv il est bien
monsieur du soir à trappes et on poisson
tu m'as fait peur si nora à bas il ne
semble pas qu'il ait prononcé ce nom-là
nom du a vu ce poisson qui n'a jamais vu
un joli but de très loin mais je n'ai vu
julie tu nous manqueras voir dans le
casier de droite en battant au kiosque
une série de dessins de poissons que je
t'avais prêter regardes tu vois je les
avais prêté
aux miracles y sont là on attendait une
médaille merci julie casimir nous allons
aller jusqu'au bout nous allons réunir
les enfants essayer de trouver le nombre
d'emplois sont d'accord très bien et
coûtent j'y vais quand nous aurons
trouvé je viendrai te le dire un peu
plus puisse commencer à préparer green
est
allongé bien tenir les enfants venez
vite a répondu moi je dis on a besoin de
vous casser mais
venez vous installer sur les bancs
voilà la pousse carte à propos de
poinçon écoutez bien les enfants
casimir voudrait trouver le nom d'un
poisson le monsieur du snob vient de
pêcher alors je vais vous montrer une
série de dessins de poissons d'eau de
mer vous allez me dire leur no je pense
que ça va aider casimir d'accord en
exigeant vous cherchez
quel est ce poisson les enfants
qu'est ce que c'est tu as raison c'est
un accroc c'est comme un accroc
c'est quelle couleur
ça le 2 août et des jolies couleurs
brillantes bleues et vertes et le ventre
nacré c'est assez bon le maquereau et
c'est pas d'une très grande finesse mais
c'est un très beau poisson bien qu'il
n'est pas ce à quoi je sers à sable et
non non non qu'est ce que c'est que ce
poisson les enfants
oui tu as raison c'est une seule sait
comment une seule la forme c'est très
plat c'est au val de souchez specht
dans la mer on va évidemment sur des
fonds sablonneux se tait en général sur
des fonds sablonneux parce qu elle se
confond avec le sable
ce n'est pas ça casimir non non c'était
pas ça du tout celui-ci
c'est ça tu as raison c'est une ré
quelle forme ça une ré c'est un losange
avec une très très longue que ça peut
être très d'avoir plusieurs mètres
luneray c'est un poisson carnassier
c'était une règle non pas si gros et pas
cette formule indien continue à celui ci
connaissent également cherché son rythme
les amphores
c'est une anguille répondu tu as raison
c'est un poisson de mer l'anguille oui
languit c'est un poisson 15 mai pour se
reproduire ça va dans la mer ça peut
avoir jusqu'à un mètre de long c'est
très très bon les anguilles c'était
d'une usine en ont déjà
celui ci
qu'est ce que c'est ça ça c'est
difficile de rascasse connaissait ça
c'est surtout en méditerranée il ya des
rascasses rouge et les grises violent
les teyrannais y en a aussi dans la
bouillabaisse
évidemment c'est ce que c'est qu'une
bouillabaisse les enfants qu'est ce que
c'est c'est un placo faits avait
énormément de poids si on connaît la
recette le casino il ya longtemps que
j'ai oublié il ya longtemps qu'est ce
que c'est que ce poisson un dauphin de
mieux vous savez tout
ah bon je n'avais pas venu de voir
dieu malines
savait que le dauphin c'est un animal
très intelligent
vous avez déjà vu faire des numéros
y en a bien été mais le nom et ça c'est
très très très intelligent c'était par
hasard donc lucchesi non non non plus
pour qui
qu'est-ce que ça surtout si non c'est
pas une si ça ça s'appelle un espèce de
poisson qui peut avoir plus que ça met
de l'eau il est désarmé du voile d'année
pro qui ressemble un petit peu à la lune
éclaire ça te trouves tu as parfaitement
raison c'était pas ça quasiment
jamais connues c'est un requin du seul
le requin c'est un poisson qui est très
long ça une gueule avec plusieurs
rangées de dents il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de sorte de requins c'était
alors heureusement monsieur des chinois
se seraient fait manger
et ceci
chercher
facilement regarder quelques risques
sexuels ses nageoires un poisson voyage
et oui bon ça fait les poissons volants
signer des baux hors de l'eau oui c est
ça plane grâce à ses nageoires qui se
remet d elle qu on appelle un poisson
volant qu'ils émigrent
c'était pas ça vous revient du mur hamas
il te plait
merci qu'est ce que c'est que celui ci
un espadon savons tout à l'heure du jeu
donnait l'accolade et tout à l'heure
c'est un poisson scie pour connaître
exactement
et celui ci le dernier
s'éteint un cabillaud et mios et de la
mort comme lundi comment as tu dis tu
habilles au cabillaud c'est curieux
c'est un nom qui ressemble à ça mais ce
n'est pas tout à fait cabillaud
pas très vendeur qu'est ce qu'un
souvenir
vous l'avez trouvée non de ce bastion à
nathan ce soit en train de réfléchir
mon la cible d'inflation au salon zone
emoa je n'arrive pas à me souvenir ce
nom
à mossoul où vous tombez vraiment bien
passé je rentre mais c'est très
important reste là je m'évade vu que ça
y est je m'en souviens du nom je m'en
souviens le voir ailleurs le poisson ni
s'agit d'un d'un godillots c'est bien ça
gaudillère pour attention ils m'ont
[Musique]